[Musik]
protestverbote bürgerfrist scheitert die
Ampel am Klimaschutz das ist unser Thema
heute liebe Zuschauer an diesem
Donnerstagabend ein herzliches
Willkommen junge Leute kleben sich auf
die Straßen einer unserer Gäste
fürchtetes Entstehen einer klimaaf ob
klimakleber mit diesen Aktionen Menschen
für ihre Anliegen gewinnen viele fühlen
sich mit dem Klimaschutz schon jetzt
überfordert jedenfalls so wie ihnen die
ampelplans z.B beim neuen heizgesetz
Verbote fristenverordnungen aber Kosten
und Machbarkeit irgendwie ungeklärt auch
die FDP kritisiert die eigene Regierung
wieder ist das was die Ampel da tut also
zu viel zu wenig oder einfach nur
schlecht durchdacht wir müssen reden mit
diesen Gästen
der
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
der Chef der CSU Landesgruppe Alexander
Dobrindt
Carla Rochel von der letzten Generation
die Ökonomen Karin pitte
und der Journalist Robin Alexander
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt die Gäste dieser Sendung
sehr herzlich bevor wir hier richtig
einsteigen eine Frage zu dem Berliner
Ergebnis von heute dem Wahlergebnis
Kevin Kühnert Generalsekretär der SPD
sie haben sich von Anfang an kritisch zu
dieser groko und der Wahl von Herrn
Wegener geäußert wie groß ist der
Schaden den die SPD da diese Regierung
schon am ersten Tag zugeführt hat auch
die SPD zugefügte wir wissen ja nicht
wer in geheimer Abstimmung die Stimmen
in zwei wahlengängen verweigert hat und
darüber möchte ich auch nicht
spekulieren aber den neu gewählte
Regierende Bürgermeister hat ja selber
gesagt dass das für eine Koalition kein
guter Staat und das ist dann wohl einer
der seltenen Momente wo ich ihm
uneingeschränkt Recht geben würde noch
mal wie groß ist der Schaden der da auch
für ihre Partei entsteht
die SPD hat sich mehrheitlich in den
Mitgliedervotum für diese Koalition
entschieden die ist jetzt auch mit der
Wahl des Regierenden Bürgermeisters
heute zustande gekommen das ist jetzt
kein rumreicher Tag sicherlich gewesen
für alle Beteiligten aber es ist jetzt
durch er ist jetzt Bürgermeister wir
wünschen ihm ein glückliches Händchen
und die Aufgaben sind groß die größten
kommen erst noch die waren nicht heute
im Plenum des Berliner
Abgeordnetenhauses wir starten in unser
Thema kleben für das Klima diese Woche
vor allem in der Hauptstadt
sie machen Ernst diese Woche mehr
Straßenblockaden der sogenannten letzten
Generation
die Nerven liegen blank bei Betroffenen
im Parlament kannst du
sitzen komm voran kommt auch die Gruppe
selbst alle politischen Forderungen
bislang unerfüllt stattdessen Vollgas
Kritik aus den Parteien die Union sieht
Extremisten am Werk müssen aufpassen
dass hier keine klima-rraf entsteht
vor Weimarer Zeiten samt
Straßenschlachten warnt die FDP
keine Mehrheit zu haben um zu sagen ich
habe aber recht und deswegen ist mir
Demokratie egal das darf in einer
Demokratie nicht stattfinden selbst die
Grünen halten Abstand
dieser Protest macht Klimaschutz nicht
mehrheitsfähig sondern verärgert Leute
spaltet die Gesellschaft
[Musik]
Kochel ist bei uns Aktivistin von die
letzte Generation glauben Sie dass Sie
die richtigen Treffen mit ihrem Protest
Vorwoche wir gehen gerade überall in
Berlin auf die Straße hunderte Menschen
sind in den letzten Tagen dazu gekommen
weil sie es nicht mehr aushalten einfach
zuzusehen wie wir weiterhin die
eskalierende Klimakrise Rasen und diesen
Protest tragen wir mitten in die
Gesellschaft weil es uns alle betrifft
natürlich wünschte ich wir müssten das
nicht machen niemand macht das von uns
aus Spaß sich hier auf Straßen zu kleben
aber was wir gerade sehen ist eine
Regierung die sich zukunftskoalition
nennt aber sich eigentlich nur
gegenseitig blockiert und die Zeit
schwindet wir haben nur noch wenige
Jahre um jetzt die Klimakrise in den
Griff zu bekommen und deshalb brauchen
Sie dass Sie die richtigen Treffen mit
ihrem Protest und was sagen sie zu dem
Vorwurf dass sie gegebenenfalls auch
Menschenleben gefährden
wir gehen auf die Straße um Leben zu
schützen ich wünschte wir müssten nur
bei den Politiker in demonstrieren wir
waren auch in den letzten Tagen immer
wieder in Regierungsviertel und direkt
mit den Politikerinnen zu sprechen die
das ganze hier zu verantworten haben
aber das kriegt niemanden mit all das
wurde auch in den letzten Jahren
versucht ich habe Petitionen ohne Ende
geschrieben habe mit bunten schildern
auf der Straße demonstriert mit Fridays
for future all das wurde ignoriert
könnte man sagen wir eröffnen mal das
Feld bei neben Ihnen sitzt
konkreterweise Alexander Dobrind der
Chef der CSU Landesgruppe im Deutschen
Bundestag Vize der Unionsfraktion die
Aktion Nerven das ist sicherlich so Herr
Dobrind sie haben auf einen Zitat der
Klima bewegten verwiesen dass da eine
neue klimaaf entstehen kann was lässt
sie vermuten dass da Terroristen am Werk
sind die Menschen jagen und umbringen
und habe gesagt wir müssen aufpassen
dass keine klimaererf entsteht will an
der Stelle auch sagen sie tragen den
Protest nicht in die Mitte der
Gesellschaft sondern sie nötigen die
Mitte der Gesellschaft und das jeden Tag
und es gibt einen Grund warum ich auch
zu dieser Aussage gekommen bin wir sehen
eine Radikalisierung und wir haben auch
darüber gelesen wie sich teile diese
Bewegung zunehmend radikaler äußern
bevor ich mich dazu geäußert habe war ja
Tatio Müller eine der
bekannten muss man sagen einer der
bekannten der Klima Szene einer
Begründer von Ende Gelände in einem
Interview und hat darauf hingewiesen
dass wir eine dreifache Radikalisierung
erleben werden eine Radikalisierung der
Klimakrise eine Radikalisierung der
Ignoranz und eine Radikalisierung der
Klima Proteste und daraus kam mir seinen
Schluss kommt der Klimaschutz nicht in
Klammern so wie er sich den vorstellt
dann kommt die grüne RAF das war hat das
dann doch massiv begründet dass das
durchaus im Bereich des Möglichen ist
und deswegen habe ich davor gewarnt das
darf nicht entstehen deswegen muss man
sich sowohl mit dem Thema
auseinandersetzen aber auch mit dem
Protesten darauf achten dass sie
deutlich radikaler werden immer dann
wenn sie Ziele nicht erreichen kommt die
nächste Stufe und deswegen ist es
durchaus berechtigt auch an der Stelle
zu sagen die Strafen müssen stärker
werden damit wir hier keine Nachnahme an
der Stelle finden es hat sich von
Freiheit für future zu der letzten
Generation schon erheblich was im
Protestverhalten getan und es ist nicht
besser geworden auf der auch geografisch
linken Seite vertreten durch Kevin kühne
die Frage beantworten kann ob die
Polizei schon zu haben zu nett mit den
Klima Klebern umgeht oder ist das
richtig wie sich politisch Polizei und
Staat gegenüber der letzten Generation
Verhalten ich glaube das im und Ganzen
die Sicherheitsbehörden genau ihrem
Auftrag entsprechend damit umgehen die
machen das ja nicht nach Gutdünken und
danach wie sie das persönlich
privatpolitisch einschätzen sondern die
haben Recht und Gesetz zu folgen und da
ihre Arbeit zu machen es gab immer
wieder Hinweise darauf dass Vorgehen zum
Teil als zu hart anerkannt wurde auch da
gibt es im Rechtsstaat Möglichkeiten so
etwas prüfen zu lassen das sind häufig
Kameras vor Ort so dass so etwas auch
betrachtet werden kann also das finde
ich muss jetzt nicht im Mittelpunkt der
Debatte stehen aber es ist einfach
offensichtlich über 80 Prozent von
Befragten auch in vielen umfragen sagen
dass sie diese Art das Protestes nicht
unterstützen und ich frage mich
tatsächlich schon auch ob ein Protest
bei dem sich als ohnmächtig empfinde
Menschen andere ohnmächtige Menschen
nämlich die auch erstmal gar nichts
unmittelbar an den Verhältnissen
verändern können blockieren wie das zu
einer Lösung der Probleme beitragen soll
meistens protestieren ohnmächtige gegen
mächtige Menschen in dem Versuch eine
Veränderung von Handlung herbeizuführen
und das scheint hier irgendwie anders zu
sein und da weiß ich nicht wieder
plausibel eine Veränderung der
gesellschaftlichen Verhältnisse trotzdem
sein möchten sehr gerne natürlich
wir haben in der Geschichte immer wieder
gesehen dass in Situationen wo einfach
eine riesengroße Ungerechtigkeit
geherrscht hat ziviler Widerstand das
Mittel war um Gesellschaften
voranzubringen um Veränderungen zu
bewirken an die vorher niemand geglaubt
hat und ich weiß dass wir uns jetzt hier
in Debatten verstricken könnten über das
Wort klimatterroristen wozu ich nur kurz
sagen möchte das zum Unwort des Jahres
letztes Jahr gewählt wurde und auch der
Verfassungsschutzbericht von Bayern am
Montag gesagt hat die Proteste die
letzte Generation diese Bewegung ist in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft verankert im
bürgerlichen Milieu all diese Leute die
da gerade auf die Straße gehen sind
verzweifelt und ich glaube was wir hier
wir uns hier einig sind ist ja dass
diese Proteste enden sollten das ist das
was wir alle wollen und deswegen würde
ich mich freuen darüber zu debattieren
wie können wir diese Proteste beenden
und darüber werden wir auch noch
diskutieren dennoch ist die Frage des
ihr Ziel legitim ist die Möglichkeiten
und die Maßnahmen die Sie ergreifen
nicht legitim und nicht immer legal sind
befürchten sie haben sie schon in einem
Gefängnis gesessen ich habe selbst auch
mehrere Tage und Nächte in Polizeizellen
verbracht und ja natürlich ist das
schrecklich und ich hätte niemals
gedacht dass ich mit 21 Jahren in einer
Polizeizelle sitzen würde
aber was bleibt mir gerade für eine Wahl
wie gesagt ich habe die letzten Jahre
alles getan was mir gesagt wurde wie ich
mich politisch engagieren kann wie ich
mich beteiligen kann nichts davon hat
gewirkt alles wurde ignoriert und
deswegen sind wir jetzt einfach an einem
Punkt ziviler Widerstand ist
demokratisch sie wieder Widerstand des
effektiv er kann funktionieren und
gerade kommen immer mehr Menschen dazu
wir sehen dass wir den Druck auf die
Regierung aufbauen können und dass wir
so aus der Klimakrise rauskommen können
Frau Rochel hat auf Joachim Herrmann
verwiesen der auch gesagt hat dass man
diese Generation die letzte Generation
nicht als terroristische Vereinigung
einordnen kann der scheint das ein
bisschen entspannter zu sehen als sie
den Status Quoten kein Mensch würde sie
jetzt als terroristische Vereinigung in
Betracht ziehen natürlich nicht ich habe
davor gewarnt was entstehen kann wenn
wir darauf nicht aufpassen und wir sehen
ja dass das Argument auch jetzt gerade
immer wieder das ist versteckt natürlich
ein bisschen die Demokratie kann ist
nicht richten ich habe mich politisch
engagiert ich habe es versucht es ist
nicht möglich meinen Willen
durchzusetzen das Parlament setzt meinen
Willen nicht um also müssen andere
Mittel ergriffen werden
es ist auch ihr Wille ist ja okay aber
dann bleiben sie einfach ja auch dabei
es wird nicht umgesetzt und deswegen
kommt ja jetzt auch diese Idee dieses
gesellschaftsrades der am Schluss
letztlich die parlamentarische
Demokratie ersetzen soll aber falsch
nein das ist nicht falsch sie schreiben
ja Update für die Demokratie ergänzend
explizit auf dass dieser
gesellschaftsrat die Entscheidungen
treffen soll die dann politisch
umgesetzt werden müssen sie nehmen der
Politik am Schluss die
Entscheidungsgewalt das heißt dem
gewählten Volksvertreter dem trauen sie
es nicht zu okay aber dann können sie
nicht diese Entscheidungen an der Stelle
ersetzen durch andere Personen die sie
treffen die aber keine demokratische
Legitimation haben das ist
brandgefährlich was sie an der Stelle
fördern
unsere Protest steht auf dem Boden der
Demokratie was wir fordern um das auch
mal kurz zu erklären was ein
demokratisch wenn Sie einen neuen Rat
auf einen demokratisch gewähltes eine
demokratisch gewählte Regierung setzen
wollen der wie auch immer
zusammengesetzt ist offensichtlich
gelöst wird
wie und warum soll der dann die
Gesellschaft besser repräsentieren
einmal kurz erklärt und dann marschieren
wir tatsächlich zu den Inhalten ja ein
gesellschaftsrat ist ein großes Gremium
160 Leute 160 Mini Deutschland alles
klar wo Leute loswerden nach nach
Geschlechter sitzen Leute vom Land und
aus der Stadt da sitzen Jugendliche
neben den Rentnern und all die werden
von Wissenschaftlerinnen informiert und
diskutieren dann über Lösungen der
Klimakrise dort wird gestritten dort
sind die Leute die es am stärksten
betrifft die auch die Maßnahmen am
stärksten betreffen und wir fordern dass
die Bundesregierung so ein
gesellschaftsrat ein dieses
demokratische Mittel steht sogar schon
im Koalitionsvertrag wir haben jetzt die
Chance dass dieser erste Bürgerrat ein
gesellschaftsrat wird wo wir über das
dringendste Problem unserer Zeit reden
über die Klimakrise
steht es im Koalitionsausschuss Papier
steht
die Ampelkoalition bekennt sich dazu
dass wir bürgerräte so heißt dieses
Modell es gibt es schon etwas länger das
hat nicht die letzte Generation erfunden
dass wir damit gerne arbeiten wollen
allerdings das ist ja ganz entscheidende
Unterschied ohne dass diese bürgerräte
bei uns eine politische handlungs- oder
weisungskompetenz hätten schon die
vergangene Koalition auch mit der Union
zusammen hat ein Bürgerrat Klima
beispielsweise eingerichtet ich habe
mich selber vor zwei Jahren damit der
damaligen Umweltministerin Svenja
Schulze mit den getroffen und das
Prinzip dass man Menschen mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Hintergrund dort ins
Gespräch bringt einander besser versteht
und das politische Akteure die dem
Zuhören und das Verfolgen besser
begreifen welche Widersprüche auch in
einer Gesellschaft sind und wie man sie
über Diskurs und Kompromissfindung
auflösen kann das funktioniert aber ich
würde immer eine rote Linie an der
Stelle ziehen wo demokratisch gewählte
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter nicht mehr
in der schlussendlichen Verantwortung
dafür sind dann auch die Entscheidungen
zu treffen das kann man nicht an ein
nicht verantwortliches Gremium
dividieren das ist auch übrigens was
ganz anders die bürgerräte als diese
gesellschaftsrat weil dieser
gesellschaftsrate ja nicht mal frei in
seiner Debatte ist weil ihm vorgegeben
ist das Klimaneutralität 2030 erreicht
werden muss alles was er am Schluss
entscheidet obliegt diese quasi
oberbotschaft 2030 Klimaneutralität und
das was der dann unter dieser
oberrichtlinie entscheidet muss dann
politisch entsprechend umgesetzt werden
wenn man das wollte das hat schlichtweg
das hat schlichtweg natürlich etwas
nicht sehr demokratisches und führt am
Schluss dazu dass sie gedanklich ja
Jahrzehnte Jahrhunderte zurück wollen
über die parlamentarische Demokratie
zurück hinaus in ständeentscheidungen
oder was ähnliches das kann man am
besten Willen nicht wollen
2030 ist das was die physikalische
Realität uns vorgibt wir müssen jetzt
wirklich aufs Tempo drücken und in den
letzten Jahren wurde unfassbar viel
verschlafen wir hätten schon viel weiter
sein können gerade sich 30 ist eine
interessante Zahl weil sie ist ja auch
jenseits der letzten Generation im
politischen Gespräch Robin alexander ist
bei uns geschätzter Kollege von der Welt
der Klimaschutz hat in diesem Land
verfassungsraum wenn junge Menschen
finden das die Parteien den Klimaschutz
nicht heftig genug umsetzen ist es dann
legitim
zu solchen Mitteln zu greifen
eine Vorstellung die den eigenen Willen
absolut setzt und das ist auch eine
Vorstellung ich bin ganz erstaunt dass
das wieder aufgekommen ist man
eigentlich Fridays for future war ja
sehr intelligent darin unser System zu
verstehen also ich meine bei den großen
Fridays for Futures Demos 2019 hat das
Kabinett damals sofort ein Klimapaket
gemacht dann waren die so clever beim
Verfassungsgericht zu klagen und neuen
Freiheitsbegriff zu wirken sie sitzen ja
auch ständig im Fernsehen Frau Neubauer
und Mitstreiterin haben sich viermal mit
Angela Merkel getroffen sie hat sich
auch mit Scholz getroffen also Sie haben
ja Zugang zu allem was unsere
Gesellschaft bietet nutzen das sehr
clever und daraus dann zu kommen dass
man denkt man kann aus diesem System
aussteigen und das muss ich sagen das
macht mir auch Sorgen weil diese Idee
dass parlamentarische Demokratie eine
schöne wetterveranstaltung wäre und wenn
es Knie Krise gäbe oder Notstand das ist
eine Idee die eigentlich von ganz rechts
kommt das ist die Rechte in den 20er
Jahren das ist Karl Schmidt und auch
diese Vorstellung man könnte einen Volks
Brillen heben am System vorbei wenn man
nur ein paar Leute und so also das sind
alles Vorstellungen die ich da gar nicht
vermutet hätte und die mir ehrlich
gesagt wirklich Sorgen machen und dann
sagen sie auf der anderen Seite im
Grunde hat diese Klimabewegung schon
wahnsinnig viel erreicht naja das ist ja
etwas was man in der Wissenschaft neue
soziale Bewegungen nennt und wenn man
jetzt überlegt die atombewegung die in
Deutschland spektakulär erfolgreich war
die haben dafür 25 30 Jahre gebraucht
und Fridays for Futures hat ja offene
Türen eingerannt und ich wiederhole mich
ich finde diesen Flirt mit dem
autoritären schwierig jetzt das Zitat
dass der Dobrind gebracht hat also diese
Klima Raff ist von einem Aktivisten in
die Debatte eingebracht worden mit
drohendem Unterton jetzt kann man sagen
der Mann ist vielleicht nicht die
hellste Kerze auf der Klima Torte aber
auch wenn man Luisa Neubauer Luisa
Neubauer hat sich in lützerath wegtragen
lassen und ein Buch hochgehalten Hans
Jonas ein kluger Philosoph in dem Buch
steht
ich empfehle das Buch zu lesen warum wir
jetzt auch für die Freiheit späterer
Generationen was machen müssen aber in
dem Buch steht auch wenn es demokratisch
nicht geht dann muss es autoritär gehen
so und jetzt dass sie das Buch hoch hält
heißt nicht dass das ihr Zitat ist in
dem Buch ist nämlich auch ein Nachwort
von Robert Habeck da sagt alles richtig
außer das autoritäre aber allein der
Flirt damit der intellektuelle Flirt mit
dem autoritären in einer Welt wo die
Auseinandersetzung zwischen Demokratie
und autoritär der größte Widerspruch ist
der führt sie wirklich eine schwere
Klippe und da kann man eigentlich nur
verwarnen
sie sind und empfehlen quasi eine
Despotie oder eine Diktatur wenn sich
die Politik nicht nach ihnen richtet wir
fordern dass wir Demokratie wirklich
leben ich möchte Demokratie wirklich
leben und die Grünen haben aktuell 16
Prozent von denen die also da würden
würde man sagen richtig harte Interessen
für grünen Umweltschutz den finden sie
zu 16 % in dieser Partei und in anderen
Parteien vielleicht nicht ganz so stark
aber wir haben ja gerade fast
festgestellt Klimaschutz hat
Verfassungsrang ich finde es immer sehr
überraschend dass das reduziert wird auf
die Grünen als wenn die dafür
verantwortlich nein alle Parteien haben
sich daran zu halten keine einzige
Partei hat genug in ihrem Parteiprogramm
um die 1,5 Grad vom Pariser Klima
Abkommen einzuhalten keine einziger so
und dann sind wir jetzt bei den
Berechtigten Vorwürfen von ihnen an die
existierenden und
Studierenden demokratischen Parteien bei
Herrn Kühnert würde mich das auch noch
mal interessieren wie lange würden Sie
sagen hat die SPD auch in der großen
Koalition davor munter diese Ziele mit
aufgeschrieben ohne auch nur in Ansätzen
daran zu denken wie man sie einlösen und
wie man sie erfüllen kann na die
prominentesten Ziele über die wir
sprechen sind ja die Ziele die das
die Vereinbarung von Paris die ja nicht
die SPD geschlossen hat sondern
Regierung selbstverständlich es ist
übrigens ein 1,5 bis 2 Grad Korridor das
muss man einfach
dazu sagen der dort beschrieben wird und
dazu bekennen sich alle und das muss
jetzt jeder im Rahmen
seiner seines Nationalstaates und der
dortigen politischen Ordnung die
herrscht das nicht über eine Demokratie
aber bei uns ist es eben schon eine
umsetzen das heißt es gibt uns den Clan
Auftrag Klimaschutz nach diesen Maßgaben
Demokratie fest umzusetzen also nach den
Gegebenheiten die unsere Rechtsstaat
hergibt und immer so das ist politisches
Geschäft dass man ein Gespür dafür haben
muss wo hat man noch die Mehrheit der
Menschen für die Maßnahmen wo verliert
man sie und was muss man dafür tun
argumentativ durch Förderprogramme da
kommen wir sicherlich gleich noch dazu
um diese Mehrheiten zu haben und wir
haben daraus abgeleitet ein
Klimaschutzgesetz das gibt's ja nicht
seit 30 Jahren sondern das gibt es seit
2019 und Herr Alexander hat recht
Fridays for future hat an zustande
kommen und derart und dem Inhalt des
klimaschutzgesetzes sicherlich einen
nicht unerheblichen Anteil und dieses
Klimaschutzgesetz gibt einen Pfad vor in
Deutschland ist der Moment beschrieben
bis 2045 bis zur Klimaneutralität danach
sogar sollen wir klimap positiv sein
also mehr einspeichern als mir imitieren
und es hat Gesetzes Charakter das ist im
Rechtsstaat eine hohe Nummer auf jeden
Fall das bindet uns nämlich und führt
eben auch zur Ableitung die für jede
Regierung daraus zu ziehen sind ganz
klar fragen wie sehr bindet das und wer
zieht wen eigentlich zur Verantwortung
wenn man diese Ziele nicht erreicht und
das ist ja die Sorge der letzten
Generation würden Sie denn sagen alles
was wir früher schaffen können müssen
wir unbedingt früher machen oder sagen
Sie
20:45 Uhr werden wir gerade so
hinkriegen
ich glaube niemand wehrt sich gegen
früher aber die Frage ist eben unter und
es geht auch früher aber geht es
Demokratie fest früher können wir einen
Pfad beschreiben umsetzen finanziell
ökonomisch organisieren der von den
Menschen mitgetragen wird wenn jede
Wahlperiode von jetzt an bis zu ihrem
natürlichen Ende geht dann haben wir bis
zu unserem Klimaziel 2045 noch sechs
Bundestagswahlen vor uns das sind wenn
Sie so wollen sechs Volksabstimmung
darüber ob der Pfad weiter verfolgt wird
oder ob Leute vielleicht auch irgendwann
gewählt werden und die Leute sagen das
war mir jetzt zu unsozial zu
rücksichtslos mit diesem Klimaschutz wir
probieren gut ohne also wir können
diesen Weg des Klimaschutz ist nicht mit
50% + einer Stimme durchziehen will ich
sagen darauf kann man nicht einen
20-25-jährigen transformationspfad einer
Industriegesellschaft mit 84 Millionen
Menschen aufbauen sondern wir werden
schon in breiten Rückhalt brauchen heißt
aber Umkehrschluss auch wir dürfen jetzt
auch nicht immer beim ersten Einwand der
gegen eine Zielsetzung kommt sofort
sagen da ist Widerstand dann lassen wir
es lieber sein und probieren es mit
Daumen drücken oder über CO2 Preise von
500 € in sich selbst ganz so viel
Widerstand wie ich freue mich dass Karin
pittel bei uns ist
energieökonomen bei Ifo-Institut in
München spezialisiert auf alles das was
wir heute diskutieren energieklima und
Ressourcen sie saßen auch in der
gaspreiskommission und haben die
Regierung auch da beraten warum Frau
Pickel diskutieren wir jetzt aus ihrer
Wahrnehmung und aus der Wahrnehmung
Fehler Menschen so hart und so radikal
und in so verschiedene Richtungen weil
wir uns endlich bewusst geworden sind
welches Ziel wir eigentlich gesetzt
bekommen haben
also in meiner Warnung ist es schon so
dass sehr lange immer wieder suggeriert
wurde Klimaschutz ist ziemlich billig
Klimaschutz ist alles nur macht Spaß ist
alles nur positiv aber das ist auch was
kosten würde und das ist in einzelnen
kosten wird und das ist auch
Verhaltensänderungen mit sich bringt das
ist lange untergegangen wir machen so
weiter wie bisher aber irgendwie
gibt's dabei keine Emissionen also ich
glaube das ist schon das eine Problem
das zweite Problem was wir haben ist
natürlich auch wir kommen aus zwei
Krisen
und dann wird die Menschen bei hoher
Inflationsrate bei zum Teil zumindest
noch hohen Energiepreisen sagt jetzt
müsst ihr wieder Geld ausgeben und das
kommt natürlich in der Bevölkerung nicht
gut an gleichzeitig wissen wir wenn wir
jetzt nicht anfangen werden wir die
2045er Ziele noch nicht mal schaffen das
heißt also da ist die Regierung wirklich
auch in einem Spannungsfeld aber ist
natürlich auch zum Teil darauf
zurückzuführen dass man nicht schon vor
Jahren angefangen hat denn was man schon
vor fünf Jahren gemacht hat in der
Klimapolitik war damals schon nicht
genug war das Verdrängung Robin
Alexander oder hat man gedacht das wird
irgendwie also die Ukraine Krieg konnten
nur wenige vorhersehen den Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine war es
Verdrängung zu sagen diese
klimapolitischen Ziele die verfolgen wir
seit den 70er Jahren Club of Rom wir
wissen dass wir was tun müssen wir
wissen immer kürzeren Fristen dass wir
immer mehr tun müssen wir unterschreiben
die Abkommen aber kümmern uns zu wenig
um die Realisation
alles zu Ende weil die haben das alles
schon vor ein paar Jahren vorher gesagt
also das ist es Gott sei Dank nicht
es ist ja auch vorangegangen also zum
Beispiel die Abkopplung von
Wirtschaftswachstum und steigenden
CO2-Emissionen die ja passiert ist die
ist keine kleine Sache das ist schon
Erfolg und ich verstehe auch dass man
Frust aufbaut wenn man durch Teil den
Frust auf wenn man sagt wenn wir so
weitermachen kann das alles nicht
klappen das ist ja das Problem also
diese 45er Ziel werden wir reißen wenn
wir nicht nachlegen auch mit den
ampelbeschlüssen das ist das kann man
wirklich ausrechnen nur man kann nicht
aus diesem gesellschaftlichen
Widersprüchen aussteigen indem man den
Leuten auf die Nerven fällt das ist also
es hilft nichts wenn man aussteigt aus
der dem Werben um Mehrheiten Kevin kühn
hat gerade sagte was kommt denn dann
wenn die Mehrheiten nicht entscheiden
dann entscheidet die Gewalt das ist so
und das ist das Problem und ähm deshalb
kann man nur davor warnen demokratische
Verfahren in Frage zu stellen weil es
gibt keine besseren ich glaube auch
nicht daran dass das ein Widerspruch ist
wenn es nicht demokratisch ist wer ist
der erfolgreichste nicht demokratische
Akteur auf der Welt die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas glaubt irgendjemand dass
die das besser hinkriegen haben die eine
bessere corona-politik gemacht die
Debatte haben wir auch geführt in
Deutschland ist das nicht viel besser
wenn cheesing Ping den Lockdown machen
kann dann hat man keinen mehr der
Einspruch erhebt und so das stimmt
überhaupt nicht
mehr aber wir sind uns doch einig darin
dass die Demokratie ein wirklich
wichtiges Gut ist was wir in langer
langer Zeit erkämpft haben und der Klima
entscheiden beispielsweise hier in
Berlin der ist gescheitert da ist 20 30
genau ausgerufen worden als Zeitraum wo
äh die Stadt Klima neutral sein soll die
Berliner haben das haben sich dagegen
entschieden das können sie nicht
akzeptieren und würden es nicht
akzeptieren und sagen wir demonstrieren
jetzt hier so lange bis ihr das anders
sieht Berliner oder hier in Berlin sind
zu wenige Menschen zu dieser Abstimmung
gegangen
und die Mehrheiten für Klimaschutz in
den Umfragen sind ja seit Jahren seit
Jahrzehnten da es wird immer wieder als
das dringendste Problem unserer Zeit
betitelt und es wird sich gewünscht dass
endlich mehr gemacht wird und was wir
uns glaube ich aber immer mal wieder
klar machen müssen auch in dieser
Debatte hier wir sind gerade nicht auf
einem guten Weg wir reißen 2030 die 1,5
Grad und die Regierung möchte 2045
klimaneutral sein das ist wirklich
einfach so Mathematik dass da irgendwas
nicht aufgeht und der
UN-Generalsekretär findet in jeder
seiner Reden drastischere Worte er sagt
wir sind auf dem Weg auf der Autobahn in
die Klima Hölle mit dem Fuß auf dem
Gaspedal und was wir jetzt brauchen ist
eine Notbremsung und ich frag mich eben
wenn man sagt hey diese Maßnahmen
umzusetzen klar das ist schwer ich weiß
es ist ein harter Job warum lässt man
sich dann nicht von einem
gesellschaftsrat unter die Arme greifen
und man sagt dann weil es ein schick mal
die Leute demokratisch diskutiert sie
können die Maßnahmen diskutieren dieser
Klimarat der 2021 hier stattgefunden hat
in Deutschland der hat unglaublich
mutige Lösungen erarbeitet und keine
einzige davon wurde umgesetzt und da
frage ich mich einfach warum nicht warum
macht man nicht dieses Detail und
vielleicht Bürgerrat auch dabei also ich
war zwar nicht als Bürger dabei aber ich
war auf der wissenschaftlichen Seite
dabei und ich fand den Dialog fand ich
auch extrem hilfreich wenn man auch
sieht was auch teilweise an
Missverständnissen da ist was teilweise
nicht nicht Erkenntnissen da ist vorher
wo sich was ändert muss ich auch nichts
ändern das ist ja beides wichtig
ich habe aber nicht den Eindruck dass
das wirklich viel bewegt hat das ist
halt auch ein Frage wie man es in die
Politik hineinträgt und wie da die quasi
die Regelungen sind aber im Prinzip ein
Rad zu haben der aus wenigen Menschen
besteht wo sie im Prinzip Gefahr laufen
dass diese Menschen nicht ihre Anliegen
vertreten das muss man ja auch immer
sagen weil sie wieder man damit umgehen
sollte und der dann im Prinzip bestimmt
auch jeglichen Demokratie Konzept was
ich haben würde und was noch hinzukommt
was zumindest bei mir jetzt so ankommt
das ist wirklich ich habe nicht den
Eindruck dass tatsächlich die Klima
Debatte die klimaschutzdebatte durch
diese Aktion befördert wird die
Diskussion wie ich höre ist nur wie geht
man da jetzt zum Beispiel strafrechtlich
mit um aber es geht nicht damit geht
nicht in die Richtung dass man sagt wir
wollen mehr Klimaschutz das ist also
insofern
man kann über die Methoden diskutieren
aber das Ziel wird aus meiner Sicht
damit nicht erreicht weil eigentlich
alle Klimaschutz ziemlich wichtig finden
und vielleicht sagen wir mal auch diese
Bundesregierung hat sich jetzt darauf
gelegt verlegt beim Heizen ernst zu
machen und hat aber in den letzten
Wochen ordentlich erstmal sich selber
eingeheizt
soll ich noch mal probieren
adieu Gas oder Ölheizung willkommen
Wärmepumpe vergangene Woche will die
Koalition endgültig den Strich und das
heißt diskutierte Gebäude Energiegesetz
machen was selbst den zuständigen
Minister in Erstaunen versetzt bitte das
mit dem Verlauf der Leute auch nicht
immer für möglich gehalten dass wir
jetzt in diesem früher das Gesetz
verabschieden drei Tage später dreht die
FDP den Regler wieder zu auf dem Partei
Tag beschließt sie das Gesetz im
Parlament nachzubessern laut Antrag
zeigt es die falsche Klima und
Energiepolitik der Grünen und eine
planwirtschaftliche Regelungswut kurz
das Ganze eine Atombombe für unser Land
sagt der Initiator es ist schon ein
Angriff auf die Eigentums Situation
vieler Menschen die Grünen schlagen
zurück für sie gehört die Novelle des
klimaschutzgesetzes zurückgedreht
den geplanten Wegfall der sektorenziele
sehen Sie jetzt kritisch und den
klimakanzler gefordert
Olaf Scholz muss selbst entscheiden ob
er seinem Versprechen gerecht wird
wenn es ernst wird mit dem Klimaschutz
der kühner dann versteckt sich Olaf
Scholz hinter der FDP oder wie darf man
das interpretieren
im Moment konkrete Vorhaben voran und
man sieht ja ich würde nicht sagen die
Widersprüchlichkeit aber eben die
Herausforderungen der Demokratie brauche
weiß zu Recht darauf hin es gibt starke
Mehrheiten in Umfragen und die können
wir auch im persönlichen Umfeld
feststellen von Leuten die sagen ich
will starken Klimaschutz und es gibt
auch viele die sagen es ist zu wenig im
Moment gerade und gleichzeitig wenn dann
konkrete Gesetzesvorhaben kommen die mit
Sicherheit noch nicht ausgereift sind
deswegen sind sie jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren und müssen
noch besser gemacht werden gibt es eben
auch große Widerstände häufig von ein
und denselben Personen und das meine ich
nicht als Vorwurf sondern dann beginnt
nämlich die Diskussion über das wie die
Ziele zu vereinbaren zusammen wir wollen
Klima neutral werden wir wollen es auch
ein bisschen schneller werden oder auch
deutlich schneller werden als bisher per
Gesetz geplant da werden sich viele
schnell einig aber wenn es dann darum
geht sehe ich das Windrad von meiner
Terrasse höre ich es vielleicht muss ich
die Heizung austauschen wie viel
Förderung bekomme ich dabei wie verhält
sich das zu meinen ein das
Vermögensverhältnissen und so weiter
dann wird es konkret dann beginnen
Gerechtigkeitsfragen Gerechtigkeit
gegenüber dem Nachbarn der Gesellschaft
insgesamt und so weiter und da beginnt
Politik und genau das passiert im Moment
gerade was man nicht tun sollte ist das
was einige Kollegen in der FDP gerade
machen nämlich anderthalb Jahre nach der
koalitionsverhandlung vergessen was man
selber ausgehandelt und unterschrieben
hat wir haben Kompromiss das ist so eine
Koalition jeden von uns sind auch ein
paar Kröten in diesem Koalitionsvertrag
drin die nun nicht in unserem
Parteiprogramm drinstanden so ist das in
jeder Koalition aber man sollte nicht
negieren was man selbst unterschrieben
hat und dass wir uns Gebäude
Energiegesetz rangehen das ist damals
unterschrieben worden und ich wiederhole
meine Frage noch mal immer wenn es
richtig ernst wird in Sachen Klimaschutz
springt der Kanzler jetzt an die Seite
der FDP wie es beispielsweise bei den
Wärmepumpen geschehen ist weil da jetzt
diese technologieoffenheit nach dem
Koalitionsausschuss drin war weil die
Ausbauziele der Autobahn man damit drin
ist weil diese sektoraufweichung drin
war da haben die Grünen ja an drei
Punkten gesagt das ist ein richtiges AUA
für uns da weiß man jetzt gar nicht wo
man zuerst anfangen soll also was die
jetzt und das ist glaube ich jetzt kein
so eine neue Frage oder keine neue Idee
die mit denen ich sie mit der ich sie
konfrontiere springt der Kanzler an die
Seite der FDP ist die Frage nein das tut
er nicht weil er distanziert sich ja
beispielsweise nicht von dem Vorhaben
dass wir über das Gebäude Energiegesetz
die Heizwände in Deutschland einleiten
müssen aber als Sozialdemokrat sagt er
dazu wie wir alle in der
Sozialdemokratie erstens dass dieses
Gesetz den Bundestag nicht passieren
wird ohne das im selben Moment die
Förderkulisse beschlossen wird wir
werden niemanden auch nur eine Stunde im
Unklaren darüber lassen wie das Ganze
dann auch abgefedert wird und wir werden
Verbesserungen noch machen müssen
gegenüber dem Entwurf der jetzt
eingereicht worden ist was bestimmt der
Altersgrenzen und Einkommensgrenzen
angeht die überzeugen mich noch nicht an
allen Stellen aber dafür haben wir ja
ein parlamentarisches Verfahren und
übrigens die Tatsache dass manches was
differenziert auch in der Koalition
diskutiert wird auch nicht einfach nach
rot gelb und grün aufzusortieren ist
sehen Sie übrigens an dem besagten
Beispiel mit den Autobahnen wo der
Koalitionsausschuss gesagt hat naja
einige Projekte die besondere
Dringlichkeit haben die können
realisiert werden wenn die Länder die
Bundesländer in denen die Projekte sich
befinden im Einvernehmen ja sagen die
Meldefrist endet in diesen Tagen nach
allem was ich höre gibt es auch einige
Rückmeldungen aus grünen mit regierten
Bundesländern in denen diese Projekte
jetzt realisiert werden sollen weil das
dann eben vor Ort doch ein bisschen
differenzierter betrachtet wird als
einfach nur Autobahn ja Nein solchen
Ausschuss er Dobrindt muss und soll
unbedingt sagen
welche Haltung die Union zu diesem
Gesetz hat ganz konkret weil es so
wahnsinnig viele Menschen betrifft und
weil ich zitiere
es offensichtlich sehr viele Menschen
auch in ihren Lebens und
Eigentumsverhältnissen trifft das war
der FDP Regel entschuldigung das ist so
da hat er Recht und bisher kennen wir ja
aus der Ampel eigentlich nur die
Drohungen und die Strafen die Drohungen
im Gesetz heißen dass ab nächstes Jahr
kann man nicht mehr frei entscheiden mit
welcher Heizung man seine Wohnung
beheizt und die Strafe sind 50.000 Euro
aber die Förderungen die es
möglicherweise geben soll die kennt man
nicht die stehen da auch nicht drinnen
gerade haben sie darauf hingewiesen
erkundet dass das im parlamentarischen
Verfahren schon noch irgendwie kommt ich
glaube das ist eine ganz große
Nachlässigkeit erstmal dass die Ampel da
vollbracht hat damit bedroht sie massiv
die Eigentümer von Wohnungen von Häusern
diejenigen die auch neu investieren
wollen und daraus entstehen enorme
Ängste und das hat man dann am
FDP-Parteitag gesehen der kommen diese
Ängste dann zum Vorschein in einem
Antrag der hier jetzt zitiert worden ist
eine große Mehrheit hat und der jetzt
wohl dazu führt dass dieses Gesetz im
Deutschen Bundestag so nicht durch den
Bundestag kommen kann ich sag mal Gott
sei Dank
ihr seid da auf der falschen Spur
sondern wir brauchen diese Neutralität
bei der Technologie wir brauchen andere
Zeitabläufe man kann den Menschen heute
nicht sagen ab dem nächsten Jahr man
weiß noch gar nicht wann das Gesetz gilt
aber auf jeden Fall ab dem nächsten Jahr
darfst du nicht mehr frei darüber
entscheiden und dann die
technologieoffenheit ist schlichtweg
nicht gegeben außer der Wärmepumpe ist
zukünftig nichts mehr zulässig wenn
dieses Gesetz so kommen würde
einschließlich Biomasse kann nicht mehr
installiert werden die Technologien
es ist Biomasse möglich es sind ganz
viele
Wasserstoff versorgt werden wir haben
kommunale Wärmenetze da ist dann der
versorge in der Karbonisieren also
dadurch wir können ja darüber streiten
das erwarte ich auch dass die Opposition
das macht aber bleiben Sie bitte einfach
Wahrheit wenn sie sagen sie machen sich
Sorgen weil die Leute sich Sorgen machen
dann sorgen Sie doch bitte nicht dafür
dass sie unbegründet noch zusätzliche
Sorgen haben
Streit haben sie doch in ihrer eigenen
Koalition das sind die FDP an uns
sondern die haben
sie adressiert hat und ich wieder an der
Stelle wir sind dankbar Frau pittel in
der Runde zu haben weil Frau Pickel wir
haben neben dem was die Koalition mit
sich vereinen muss und klären muss einen
Mangel an Handwerkern einen Mangel noch
an Wärmepumpen wir haben eine
ja wir haben einen Mangel natürlich auch
an diesen berühmten Zulassungen durch
die BAFA ich will jetzt die Komplexität
sozusagen einer Beantragung gar nicht zu
groß machen für wie realistisch halten
sie das ab 1
24 in den neu zu bauenden Häusern
Wärmepumpen eingebaut werden
ungefähr bei 50 Prozent werden jetzt
schon Wärmepumpen eingebaut aber
trotzdem die Zahlen die in der Politik
quasi gehandhabt werden von einer halben
Millionen pro Jahr sehe ich nicht wie
die machbar werden mit den Handwerkern
die wir bisher haben das heißt der
Vorlauf ist extrem kurz das heißt wenn
ich das ein paar Jahre vorher
angekündigt hätte dann wären zum
Beispiel wäre klar gewesen der Markt
kommt ich kann im Prinzip auch Leute
einstellen ausbilden oder kann ich dann
auch als Handwerker tatsächlich meine
Auftragsbücher füllen und dieser kurze
Vorlauf der ist einfach viel zu kurz
also ich mache mir weniger Sorgen darum
dass keine Wärmepumpen da sind weil die
kann ich auch importieren da kann ich
auch Regelungen ändern
und
unsere Solaranlagen kommen nicht nur aus
China das ist der Punkt ich meine wir
wollen ja nicht nur aus einem Land wir
wollen diversifizieren und da können die
aus Deutschland kommen aus den USA
kommen
wir gerade bei Viessmann dass der
Verkauf an die Amerikaner natürlich mit
diesem Gesetz auch zu tun viele Firmen
wir kommen noch mal dazu genau und dann
ist ja aber bleibt es dabei wenn bleibt
die Frage bestehen natürlich halten Sie
es für realistisch dass das Gesetz zu
diesem Zeitpunkt
ich sehe nicht also ob das Gesetz des
Licht der Welt abliegt das bin ich da
bin ich nicht sicher aber ich denke wenn
es das Licht der Welt ablegt wenn man
relativ schnell Ausnahmen und
Sonderregelungen Übergangsregelungen etc
schaffen müssen weil es einfach nicht
umzusetzen ist in der Kürze der Zeit wir
sind noch bei den wir sind noch bei den
politischen gegeben für ganz normale
Fälle tatsächlich auch sagt okay ihr
könnt jetzt doch noch einbauen meine was
mache ich denn wenn jemand sein also
wenn sozusagen unter allen bisherigen
Richtlinien jemand keine Gasheizung mehr
einbauen sollte wenn ich meinen
Gasheizung einbauen mit der Garantie
dass du so Wasserstoff umgestellt wird
kann mir Moment schlecht vorstellen dass
das tatsächlich Firmen aussprechen also
kann es eigentlich niemand machen und
dann erlauben wir noch den über
80-Jährigen Omas dass sie die Gastherme
einbauen besagt sich der Normalbürger
auch okay dann gucke ich mal dass die
Oma noch lange lebt oder dass ich ihr
wenn ich es nicht schon getan habe das
häuschenüberschreibe ich meine der
Gedanke dahinter ist natürlich klar dass
man sagt bei 80-jährigen dass er quasi
der Lebenshorizont nicht mehr so groß
ist irgendwo das Verständnis nicht dafür
da diese Ausnahme weil die 77-Jährige
darüber haben wir hier schon diskutiert
dass sie natürlich tatsächlich die
Unterstützung bräuchten aber mit welcher
Legitimität fangen wir da jetzt bei 80
an habe ich ja eben schon durchblicken
lassen es beginnt jetzt das
parlamentarische Verfahren es ist hier
ein Parlamentarier der ihn gerade gesagt
hat wie seine Auffassung dazu ist ich
hielte beispielsweise den Übergang in
ein Rentensystem welches auch immer für
ein plausiblen Zeitpunkt weil sich dort
an der Einkommenssituation dann etwas
ändert was in der Regel dann auch
weiterhin so bleibt das ist auch für
viele Hausbanken der Moment in dem die
Kreditwürdigkeit sich verändert das
machen wir jetzt im parlamentarischen
Verfahren ich verstehe dass das jetzt
komplex ist denn jeder in Deutschland
hat was mit Heizung zu tun die Lebens
die heizsituation die
Einkommensverhältnisse alles ist hoch
unterschiedlich und ich verstehe das
Bedürfnis weil alle betroffen sind das
jetzt alle auch schnell wissen wollen
was es für mich Phase es wird aber kein
Gesetz geben von welcher Koalition
dieser Welt auch immer dass ich mit den
Heizungen im ganzen Land beschäftigt und
auf drei Seiten mit drei schnellen
Spiegelstrichen klar macht wie das
laufen soll ein solches Gesetz würde
niemand zurecht als gerecht empfinden
ich bin aber dafür dass wir diese
Klarheit schnell individuell herstellen
ich bin z.B dafür dass wir dafür sorgen
dass individuelle sanierungsfahrpläne
etwas was über das BAFA heute schon
beantragt werden kann wo man mit einer
hohen zu Förderung mal so schnell Zettel
bekommt der einem Ausweis was ist mit
meinem Gebäude eigentlich wie ist das
Beschaffen was könnte da geändert werden
werde ich vielleicht bald dann
entwärmenetz angeschlossen dass wir das
allen Eigentümern jetzt zeitnah
zugänglich machen dass sie das am besten
auch kostenlos bekommen können damit wir
meine individuelle Fall Klarheit
bekommen was ist mit meinem Gebäude
erstmal wegkommen von dem allgemeinen
Geraune uns alle wird eine Welle
überrollen hinzu was ist mit meinem
Gebäude was will die Regierung dort wie
hilft sie mir und wie ist das Quartier
organisiert nach der Gesetzgebung
nachdem das Kabinett so was beschlossen
hat diskutiert werden also
offensichtlich ist dieses Gesetz Murks
ansonsten würden sie jetzt nicht an
jeder Stelle beim Zeitplan bei den
Förderungen bei der Technologie zu einem
Ergebnis kommen da muss man jetzt noch
mal neu drüber reden dieses Gesetz ist
von vorne bis hinten falsch wir haben
Angeboten etwas anderes zu machen wir
haben gesagt wir können uns über abfragt
Prämien möglicherweise unterhalten hohe
Förderungen freiwillige austausche lange
Fristen an der Stelle und nicht
irgendwelche Jahreszahlen um 80-jähriger
oder ein Sozialhilfeempfänger vielleicht
50% der Förderung kriegt wo soll die
anderen 50% her können dieses Gesetz
verunsichert die Leute es macht ihnen
Angst und ich habe Verständnis dafür
dass das Angst macht weil
weil eine heizungsanschaffung für die
meisten Menschen eine der größten
Anschaffungen ist die sie im Laufe ihres
Lebens tätigen und 40 50 60.000 Euro und
sie sagt mal auf die Schnelle ab dem
nächsten Jahr ist alles anders und du
bist betroffen und du bist mit dieser
Summe dabei das würde mir auch Angst
machen Robin Alexander
wird es dieses Gesetz überhaupt geben ja
also das Gesetz so geben dass man das
Gesetz noch erkennt
ich habe jemanden getroffen der sagte
das würde auf 170 Seiten rauslaufen dass
das ist wirklich dicke aber ich würde
gerne auf ein Widerspruch in unserer
Diskussion Hinweisen wir haben die erste
Zeit damit verbracht der Aktivistin zu
erklären warum sie auf demokratische
Verfahren vertrauen soll und seitdem
erklären Vertreter demokratischer
Verfahren warum es nicht so schnell
gehen kann also längere Fristen abrenten
Eintrittsalter nicht mehr umbauen und
und und und das ist ein dann muss man
natürlich sagen wenn man die Debatte so
führt geht man den vorher weil das ist
dann zu langsam also man kann nicht
sagen Klimaneutralität
2045 und 20 40 70 im ungedämmten Haus
mit der Öl oder Gasheizung das passt
nicht zusammen also da ist dann schon
auch wenn wir sagen das Gefühl komplett
weil es natürlich ein einziges Thema
jetzt nimmt die Wärme und nicht darüber
spricht der Alexander wie können wir
sonst mit CO2 umgehen zum Beispiel ob
CO2 Einlagerung unter der Erde die
ccs-technologien gehen heute natürlich
auch und sind ein wesentlicher
Bestandteil wenn man zukünftig an
Technologie denkt die auch gegen den
Klimawandel gerichtet ist und deswegen
nochmal ohne die Unterstützung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wird auch der
Klimaschutz nicht funktionieren wenn wir
die Leute nicht an unserer Seite haben
wird es nicht klappen und wenn wir die
und wenn wir die Leute bei diesen
Investitionen nicht an unserer Seite
haben dann wird es auch später keine
Nachahmer geben ein deutscher Weg beim
Klimaschutz der am Schluss den Wohlstand
nicht mit sichern kann wird weltweit
niemanden finden der das Nachahmen will
und alleine retten wir das Klima nicht
wir brauchen Nachahmer das auch unser
Anspruch wir wollen vorausgehen damit
andere entsprechend dem auch nachfolgen
können aber so wird's nichts
mehr der Führer im Klimaschutz für waren
mal wir hatten mal den Ruf aber den
haben wir schon lange verloren ich
wollte ihn noch mal meine Frage erklären
ich wollte gerne wissen ob man mit dem
Bedürfnis und zwar mit der Verpflichtung
und den Bedürfnis dringend unsere
Situation zu heizen zu verändern
vielleicht doch über Alternativen reden
sollte die Menschen dazu zu motivieren
als mit einem Gesetz das ab ersten
ersten 24 beginnt also noch mal die
Frage tun wir zu viel wahrscheinlich
nicht tun wir zu wenig oder tun wir es
bisher schlecht ist dieses Angebot in
Bezug auf das Heizen wirklich ein
Angebot an die Leute 90% sagen nein und
das ist dann vielleicht ein Votum was
auch vor hoch interessiert aber sie
sagen nein vielleicht zu einem Gesetz
was einfach nicht gut gemacht ist
also noch ist das Gesetz ja nicht da
also nicht den Start brechen über ein
Gesetz das ist noch nicht gibt aber die
die Idee dass das ohne Förderung
rauskommt die ist Quatsch also die die
Förderung war ja jetzt schon bei
bestimmten Modellen bis zu 40% jetzt
gehen die noch mal höher also das wird
was und auch diese Preise für die
Wärmepumpen werden fallen das das ist so
aber ich bin auch und trotzdem kann
Experte das müsste ich an sie
weiterreichen aber prinzipiell würde ich
auf den weil ich finde gerade weil wir
so hart reden über die Leute die da an
der Straße kleben und ich bin ja einer
davon der hat redet muss man sich auch
ehrlich machen dann muss man in
demokratischen Prozess auch liefern und
wir werden alles brauchen also wir
werden das Zeug unter die Erde pressen
müssen wir werden was machen im Verkehr
und im Geburt also diese Idee Gebäude
ist jetzt hart für die Leute machen wir
woanders wenn wir alles überall machen
selbst dann wird es noch schwierig
nichts geschehen soll sondern man könnte
sich ja einfach ein Beispiel nehmen
daran wie andere Länder genau diese
Frage gelöst haben um paradigmatisch zu
zeigen ob wir jetzt besonders gut mit
dieser Frage Dämmung und Wärme umgehen
ich frage noch mal Frau Pickel es gibt
andere Länder zum Beispiel die
Skandinavier die das mit einer CO2
Bepreisung gemacht haben die haben wir
eigentlich auch wir haben sie bis zum
Ende der Legislaturperiode ausgesetzt
und haben offensichtlich auch davor
Angst gehabt dass die Preise eben der
Energien also Gas und Strom steigen und
haben dann mal schnell einen Tankrabatt
weil wir Angst haben dass die Leute
tatsächlich belastet werden so noch mal
die Frage gäbe es alternativen zu dem
was wir machen also in eine bestimmte
Industrie staatlich hinein verpflichten
nämlich in die Wärmepumpe mit den
möglichen Alternativen die technische
aber noch gar nicht da sind
gibt es eine Alternative zu diesem Weg
der CO2-Preise reizen natürlich dann
Wechsel an das heißt sie zeigen einem
deutlich was man an Schäden verursacht
und die zeigen auch deutlich was es vor
Vorteile haben könnte auf eine andere
Technologie zu wechseln also insofern
bin ich ganz dafür auch ein
Emissionshandel führt dazu dass man
wirklich die Emissionen über die Zeit
sich herunterbringt aber was man dann
natürlich nicht machen kann ist den
Preis in der Hinsicht zu begrenzen wie
es jetzt geplant ist also aus selbst für
den EU-Emissionshandel der kommen soll
in ein paar Jahren wird angestrebt den
Preis nicht höher als 45 Euro pro
Zertifikat also für die Emission einer
Tonne zu haben das macht fast nichts was
den Gaspreis angeht aus das heißt man
braucht eigentlich viel viel höhere
Preise damit man tatsächlich die
Reaktion nämlich den raus aus dem Gas
und rein in die Wärmepumpe damit
erreicht und das wird auch wieder zu
Widerständen führen und wird auch in
Kosten verbunden sein das heißt also man
muss irgendwann mutig sein und da gebe
ich Ihnen recht also das wird nicht
immer gleich populär sein und man wird
wahrscheinlich früh in der
Legislaturperiode besser als später
machen aber es wird auf jeden Fall nicht
ohne Kosten abgehen
Klimaschutzgesetz eine co2-bepreisung
festgelegt die rauswächst aus den Festen
bepreisungsschritte in die
Marktwirtschaft und dann wird der Preis
am Markt gebildet und das ist der Punkt
wo natürlich dann CO2 Emissionen teuer
werden können muss der Punkt wo dann
auch marktwirtschaftlich entschieden
wird in welche alternativen Technologien
geht man rein und zu wissen was auf
einen zukommt gibt die Möglichkeit der
Investition auch den privaten Leuten und
das ist ja der Unterschied wir brauchen
einen Fahrplan auf dem wir sowas
entscheiden können und man weiß was
kommt auch ein Kosten auf einen zu dann
kann man sich entscheiden frühzeitig
auch in eine Alternative Technologie zu
gehen aber nicht den Zwang des Auslösens
innerhalb wenigen Monaten zu
Investitionsentscheidungen die Leute
nicht stemmen können
aber wenn sie natürlich dann bei der
ersten Widerstand schon den CO2-Preis
Anstieg aussetzen
natürlich weil ihre Waren im letzten
Jahr da brauche ich doch nicht mal
symbolischen Aufstand 5 Euro mehr die
Tonne bei CO2 heißt
irrsinnig viel mehr Energiepreise als
vorher und jetzt braucht er noch 5 €
mehr die Tonne damit ihr versteht ihr
Lieben Bürger also das Energie teuer ist
und gespart werden
wie lange nicht weil der Preis schon
extrem hoch gewesen
sind wir vorsichtig und sagen ungefähr
0,2 Cent ausmachen also insofern
Preis bremsen aber die Regierung packt
noch was beim CO2-Preis aber ja ich
denke aus der klimapolis
problematisch ja aber das ist die Idee
aber die wissen auch wer damals dafür
gesorgt hat dass es nicht bei dem
Preisen eingestiegen ist wie es grüne
und schwarze Kanalhafen
der Preis zu dem sie im Prinzip
hochgehen ist 55 bis 65 danach wird
entschieden ob ich denn tatsächlich den
Preis dem Markt überlasse oder nicht wir
haben auf dem europäischen auf der
europäischen Ebene jetzt schon fast 100
€. das heißt das ist nicht viel das sind
nicht die Erwartungen die tatsächlich
diese diese Umwälzungen die man damit
haben könnte und auch induzieren könnte
wirklich auch bekommen kann also das
sind einfach noch
im Gesetz
jemals wieder
nach dem ein Jahr wo wenn der Bandbreite
sind das tatsächlich frei wenn Alexander
also das wird doch zum Kern das Problem
ist man kann es machen wie wir es Habeck
versucht hat man sagt einfach Stichtag
und dann dürft ihr nur noch so und so
oder man kann es machen über den Preis
das halte ich für die elegantere
marktwirtschaftliche Lösung aber es wird
auch hart das wird total hart so und
dann kann man ja dieses berühmte
Klimagerät oder die sogenannte Klima
Dividende dagegen packen und hätte für
die Menschen die ebensozial schwächer
sind eine Zurückzahlung dieser Höhe
steigenden Kosten ja aber die Politik
müsste halt die Kraft aufbringen dann
das auch also ich ein Beispiel auf
diesem fdp-partei da wurde ja nicht nur
beschlossen worüber schon der Sprachen
da wurde auch beschlossen den CO2-Preis
vorzuziehen auf Gebäude und Verkehr
auszuweiten auf 20% wieder 20 jetzt also
ein paar Monaten
Liebe in der Vergangenheit
so und nach diesem Beschluss der der in
die Richtung geht in diese argumentieren
hat sich Lindner vor die Kamera
ausgestellt hat gesagt keine Sorge
machen wir nie ist technisch nicht
möglich und ihr Koalitionspartner sich
das anders also die streiten auf der
abstrakten Ebene für den
marktwirtschaftliches Konzept aber wenn
es Eingemachte geht dann nicht weil das
hätte die gleichen Härten und das
Problem wäre doch jetzt eine System zu
finden wahrscheinlich wird seine
Kombination sein außer Ordnungsrecht und
Markt
dass dieses Anreiz diese Umstellung aber
die Umstellung brauchen wir schon also
egal wie diese Debatte ausgeht wenn die
Debatte aus geht weitermachen
dazu geführt dass Schweden Finnland
ausgestattet ist mit Wärmepumpen also
die Frage ist in anderen Ländern hat das
schon ganz gut funktioniert und noch mal
national CDU schlägt jetzt vor das ist
eine nationalen Emissionshandel ab 2024
geben soll und diese Klima Dividende und
da scheitern wir also CDU forder dass
die FDP fordert das aus der Regierung
so deshalb frage ich
wir sind nicht alternativlos wäre das
gegebenenfalls sogar gerechter und würde
es vielleicht auch weniger Geld kosten
das ist doch eine Frage wo sie politisch
stehen also ich kann ja nicht von Kevin
Kühnert verlangen dass er die
Klimapolitik supermarktwirtschaftlich
ausrichtet und ich kann nicht von der
FDP verlangen dass sie auf den
regulierenden Staat setzt nur die
Debatte muss sich verlagern auf wie
machen wir das und nicht auf habe
gelichten Gesetz vor und alle überlegen
sich wie kriegen wir ihn davon wieder
runter damit sage ich gar nicht dass das
Gesetz besonders toll wäre wir haben in
der Welt 35 Leitartikel mit den
Schwächen des Gesetzes geschrieben aber
die Debatte müsste auf uns wie gehen und
nicht mehr ums ob das geht ja nicht ums
ob sondern ich fragte nur noch mal nach
einer inhaltlichen Alternative weil
diese Alternative erfolgreich war in
anderen Ländern mit Wärmepumpen und
jetzt kehre ich wieder zu den
natürlich teilweise auch mehr
Ausstattung einer neuen Energien hat
muss man auch
sagenenergie haben als wir und auch
weiter in die Kernenergie investieren an
dieser Stelle müssen wir doch auch mal
kurz festhalten dass wir jetzt hier
gerade ewig über eingesetzt diskutiert
haben über die Details über hin und her
das ist wichtig
aber
was wir daran auch festhalten können ist
das ist jetzt gerade eine Maßnahme was
wir brauchen und was auch das Menschen
betrifft im Land das auch das
Verfassungsgericht sagt ist wir brauchen
einen Plan die Regierung hat gerade
keine Ahnung was die Maßnahmen die Sie
machen bewirken wir brauchen einen Plan
dass die Leute auch wirklich planen
können und vor allen Dingen müssen wir
darauf achten dass diese Maßnahmen
sozialgerecht umgesetzt werden können es
kann einfach nicht sein dass der
Landwirt der seinen Traktor bekannt oder
der Handwerker der sein Auto betankt die
CO2-Steuer zahlen muss und die
Superreichen die ihre Luxusyachten
betanken die nicht
die armen Menschen und die Mittelschicht
das sind die die jetzt gerade schon
unter der Klimakrise Leiden das sind die
bei denen die Ernten Ausfällen fallen
bei denen wirklich die Existenzen auf
dem Spiel stehen in Spanien ist es
gerade jetzt schon so heiß das 60 bis 80
Prozent werden und dennoch ich
rede realistische über eine Realität
in diesem Land das betrifft die ihre
Gebäude ihre Wohnungen die müssen heizen
wie würden sie das denn sozial lösen ich
glaube dass das genauso Punkt ist der
wunderbar in so einem gesellschaftsrat
zu diskutieren und die Leute drin sind
Gremium einführen nachdem wir schon
erlebt haben wie viele Gremien darüber
schon gesprochen haben und
offensichtlich Regierung dann jetzt aber
echt schneller mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz als wenn wir jetzt erst
noch den gesellschaftsrat einsetzen
zu machen na ja das kriegen wir schon
noch diese sind aber das ist doch was
vielleicht könnte man sagen und zwar
ganz konkret sagen wie sie ist lösen
würden wie würden sie das sozial machen
es kostet wahnsinnig viel Geld dieses
wahnsinnig viele Geld kann nicht zu 80%
vom Start kommen oder würden sie fordern
dass das zu 80% vom Start kommen ich
glaube dass wir uns jetzt als
Gesellschaft überlegen müssen was wir
uns noch leisten können können wir uns
die Reichen und die Superreichen leisten
mit ihren Luxusyachten mit dem
Privatjets sollten wir das nicht mal
beschränken weil dann ist auch wieder
Geld da um sozial gerecht sondern Wandel
anzuschieben und was ich an der Stelle
auch mal gerne sagen würde ist wir
machen Prozesse Frage wir gehen in den
Protest wir sind nicht die Leute die das
entscheiden das will ich niemand von uns
ich würde gerne einfach studieren ich
würde einfach gerne Vertrauen in diese
Regierung haben dass ich auch in 20 30
Jahren noch was zu essen habe also ich
meine Kinder nicht verhungern sie möchte
dieses Vertrauen das versteht haben und
ich stehe auch zu einer soziale Bewegung
ist nicht dazu da Gesetzesvorschläge
vorzulegen das ist nicht ihr Job was in
der Vergangenheit bei anderen auch nicht
aber wir müssen das tun wenn wir um
Zustimmung werden
wenn jetzt von allen Seiten so
wahnsinnig begeistert immer wieder
gesagt wird dann drehen wir halt einfach
den CO2 Preis hoch weil Preise sind
super wirksamer Markt und dann merken
Leute das und selbst wenn ich was
eigentlich gar nicht geht ne System
erfinde in dem nur reiche bepreist
werden oder nur Unternehmen bepreis
werden mit CO2 die Stellen ja die
Produkte bereit die andere am Ende
kaufen die produzieren CO2 bepreis die
Lebensmittel die arme Menschen im
Supermarkt am Ende kaufen müssen und wo
sie dreimal den Euro umdrehen die
produzieren die Wärmeträger mit denen am
Ende die Heizung die ich nur im Keller
habe betrieben werden muss und natürlich
funktioniert ein Preis ein Preis sagt
mir erst mal davon muss ich weg das wird
jetzt teuer die Regierung macht das
teurer als das noch teurer wird das Öl
muss weg was ist nicht löst das Problem
die ganze Zeit besprochen haben wenn ich
zu der Erkenntnis gelangt bin der alte
Ölkessel muss raus ich brauche was
regeneratives dann gehe ich zu meinem
Energieberater und dann sagt er mir naja
je nachdem gut oder habe ich und stell
dich mal auf eine mittlere fünfstellige
Summe ein
dann stehe ich da und sage ist nicht
vorhanden Regierung was nun und dann
sind wir am entscheidenden Punkt
angekommen und deswegen lohnt es sich
nicht nur in dieser Sendung sondern auch
sonst ganz viel über förderfragen zu
sprechen nicht weil man dem eigentlichen
Kern der Debatte aus dem Weg gehen will
sondern weil sich hier ganz individuell
für jede Wähler und jede WählerInnen in
Deutschland entscheidet ob Sie an Bord
sind oder nicht machen wir es noch mal
konkret 40 Prozent oder 20 Prozent und
trotzdem hätte ich gedacht dass sie
vielleicht sagen was Sie für eine
gerechte Lösung halten würden in dieser
konkreten Frage kriegt man jetzt wenn
man investiert es sind wenigstens 40%
die bleiben noch zustimmen aber wir
erinnern uns das Robert Habeck
versprochen hat dass die Differenz
zwischen einer normalen Gastherme und
diese Wärmepumpe durch den Staat
getragen wird ich bin jetzt nicht der
Pressesprecher von Robert habe zu Ende
ja ich habe ihm zu Ende zugehört und
er hat es glaube ich so gemeint dass er
gesagt hat über im rollenden Mittel über
die folgenden Jahren nämlich dadurch
dass der Energieträger mit dem man diese
neue Heizung dann betreibt ja viel
günstiger ist als der alte Energieträger
Öl oder Gas was immer teurer wird in den
nächsten Jahren dadurch amortisiert sich
das gleicht sich das über die Jahre
sozusagen aus das ist auch richtig aber
hier sind wir wieder an dem
beschriebenen Problem von eben das ist
dann eine entspannte Rechnung wenn man
was auf der hohen Kante hat und sagen
kann prima das trägt sich über die
nächsten Jahre ab die die nichts auf der
hohen Kante haben und die sagen ich
brauche eine
finanzierungsunterstützung oder ein
zinsloses Darlehen oder was auch immer
damit ich das Abtragen kann die gucken
jetzt auf uns und die werden sich sehr
genau dieses Gesetz an gucken weil es
darüber entscheidet ob sie den Weg auch
mitgehen können und deswegen lohnt es
sich so viel dort über soziale
Gerechtigkeit jetzt auch konkret zu
reden natürlich ein Problem haben weil
sie überhaupt gar nicht verstehen was
Eigentümer von
Mehrfamilienhäusern da jetzt tun und
entscheiden
groß Frau pittel noch mal wir sind
leider am Ende der Sendung wie groß ist
ihre Hoffnung dass da rechtzeitig ich
frage es noch mal ein gutes Gesetz
herauskommt mit dem die Menschen dann
tatsächlich auch einigermaßen lebten
also rechtzeitig das für die Klimaziele
noch erreichen können aus meiner Sicht
die Hoffnung ist da ich denke ich darf
es einfach auf der einen Seite nicht zu
kompliziert machen was ich vorschreibe
was waren wenn ich das denn vorschreibe
und keinen Preis oder kombiniere aber
ich muss mir ganz viele Gedanken darüber
machen das wird glaube ich deutlich wie
ich das auf der sozialen Seite löse und
das ist einfach wir können heute keine
Gesetze mehr machen wo wir sagen wir
Männer die Emission aber wir denken
nicht gleichzeitig mit wie das sozial
geht und da helfen uns auch die Yachten
und die Privatflugzeuge so viel das ist
natürlich irgendwann klar dass das
sollte nicht sein und das sind völlig
verschwendete Emissionen gehe ich mit
ihm mit aber wenn wir die weg haben
dann haben wir die Klimaziele noch lange
nicht erreicht das ist eine gewisse
sogar suggestionsdebatte hier das im
Prinzip immer gesagt wird wenn die
Reichen dass sie ändern dann sind wir
gut dran aber wir müssen uns alle wir
müssen uns alle beteiligen und wir
müssen alle auch gewisse Kosten auf uns
nehmen ich denke das sollte man nicht
verschleiern und man kann nicht immer
nur sagen ja wenn wir keine
Privatflugzeuge mehr haben dann ist die
Welt gut
gar nicht die Tatsache aber die Frage
wie reagieren
so lange ausgeführt haben dass sie jetzt
über die soziale Gerechtigkeit in diesem
Gesetz mit den Heizungen reden müssen
heißt der ganz offensichtlich das ist
die Ampel bisher nicht getan hat und das
ist dieses Gesetz eben nicht
sozialgerecht ist wenn Sie jetzt auf den
Trichter kommen dass das gelöst werden
muss sind wir vielleicht schon mal einen
Schritt weiter wünsche dir viel viel
Glück ob das gelingt wenn man sie aber
ein bisschen hat mich ehrlicherweise
gefrostet wird wenn das so sage aber mit
diesem Hinweis wir können uns die
reichen nicht mehr leisten ich glaube
ihn persönlich dass sie die Demokratie
nicht abschaffen wollen damit wir uns da
vollkommen klar sind aber ihre Ziele
sind am Schluss nicht demokratisch und
sie haben inzwischen einen Sound und ein
würding da hat man manchmal Zweifel was
wollen Sie denn eigentlich damit
wirklich umsetzen und übrigens ihre
Taten sind strafrechte also von daher
würde ich sagen bitte dann noch mal
drüber nachdenken was eigentlich
dahinter steht wenn man ständig versucht
Dinge in die Debatte einzuwerfen die am
Schluss den demokratischen Prozess nicht
nur stören sondern ihn verhindern werden
das glaube ich ist nichts was wir
gemeinsam miteinander das Recht bricht
wir wollen die Demokratie erhalten
das ist nicht meine Regierung ich habe
sie nicht gewählt und aber sie ist
demokratisch zustande gekommen daran
kann ich jetzt erstmal nichts ändern
ja und sie bricht an der Stelle
definitiv nicht die Verfassung aber was
sie machen ist dass sie Straftaten
begehen verwechseln Sie jetzt einfach
nicht diese Dinge miteinander dieses
Gesetz
schnell zu hastig gemacht weil wir so
viel Zeit vorher verloren haben Robin
Alexander also die Ölheizung war auch
schon von der großen Koalition verboten
und dann stand im Koalitionsausschuss
dass die das machen mit was die
wärmewende nennen und dann ist es unter
dem Eindruck dass der russischen
Invasion in die Ukraine in einem
Koalitionsausschuss vorgezogen worden
der auch schon wieder ein Jahr her ist
und die Pläne die da von Harburg
verfolgt sind ja von seinem Staat in der
Patrick reichen vorher agora glaubt ein
Papier von 2018 die Wärmepumpe Wände
also alles jetzt nicht aus dem Hut
gezogen
nur es gibt halt keine politische
Einigung also das was jetzt stattfindet
in diesen 23 Stunden Koalitionsausschuss
jetzt sagt die FDP wir sind im Kabinett
dafür machen aber ein Protokollerklärung
wir sind da gegen und auf dem Parteitag
und jetzt wieder in die Fraktion da ist
einfach ein politischer
Konflikt nicht ausgetragen worden und
das wird jetzt nachgeholt auf offener
Bühne im Parlament und dann machen wir
an dieser Stelle einen Punkt ich darf
mich bedanken für die Diskussion es wird
nicht unsere letzte Sendung zu diesem
Thema gewesen sein
gebe weiter zu Markus Lanz der heute
unter anderem Herbert Grönemeyer zu Gast
hat und wir sehen uns ich spreche schon
schneller nächste Woche wieder 22:15 Uhr
wenn Sie Zeit haben und mögen bis dahin
kommen
[Musik]